I think Trump, in lots of ways, is a refreshing
reminder
that the guy that's in the White House is
another human being.
And that bringing that power back to human
scale is an important part
of what needs to be done to correct the insanity
that's been going on in the post-war era,
Louis Rossetto is the co-founder of Wired
Magazine
and the co-recipient of the very first Lanny
Friedlander Prize from Reason.
It honors an individual or group who has created
a publication,
medium, or distribution platform that vastly
expands human freedom.
In 1971, while an undergraduate at Columbia
University,
he co-authored a story in the New York Times
Magazine titled,
"The New Right Credo: Libertarianism".
"Liberalism, conservatism, and leftist radicalism
are all bankrupt philosophies," he wrote.
"Refugees from the old right, the old left,
and the new left are organizing independently
under the banner of libertarianism."
Rossetto's newest project is a novel
called, "Change is Good: A Story from the
Heroic Era of the Internet,"
which he and designer Erik Spiekermann launched
on Kickstarter.
The project raised nearly 200,000$ and is
going out to backers now.
Louis, thanks for talking.
Pleasure to be here.
What's the plot of, Change is Good?
It's a novel right?
That's an easy question to start with.
There are six characters, each of them have
their own stories.
I suppose for you, at this moment,
the most interesting thing about the book
is the focus on that time.
The book is set in the 1990's.
The 1990's were this pivotal moment in world
history, where ...
Well, cast your mind back.
It was a period of unbelievable optimism.
The Cold War is over.
The internet is taking off.
It's becoming a mass medium.
The Cold War end-
The economy is doing great.
The Cold War ends at the beginning of the
90's.
The internet takes off with the arrival of
the web.
The period ... There's drugs: ecstasy.
The rave culture.
Multiple different levels there are massive
changes going on that are affecting all aspects
of our life.
The 90's is this pivotal moment where there's
this burst of optimism.
Young people are arriving in this new space,
the internet, the web,
digital technologies in general.
There's a sense that the future is utterly
malleable.
For the first time in a long time, after the
Cold War,
the fear and anxiety of the Cold War, now
there's this open running room.
It's the end of history, literally.
Fukuyama says so.
Now, anything's possible.
Any weird, crazy idea that you have, is no
longer bound by normal restrictions,
like finance, or law, or even physical bounds.
It is incredibly hard to go back to those
early days of even pre-internet culture.
Even AOL, American Online, had the walled-garden,
where people were anonymous.
You had fake names that you would use and
talk about anything.
Usenet groups.
You could reproduce things cheaply.
DVD players were 7$, or whatever.
I mean, companies that had zero income had
billion dollar valuations.
Companies were more valuable than General
Motors
that were selling in the tens of millions
of dollars.
It had Bill Clinton saying the era of big
government is over.
There were all sorts of things happening in
society, at that moment,
in all levels of society,
that were pointing toward a millennial future
that was going to be almost utopian.
There were people involved, in the 90's, that
were making that happen.
The gen-X'ers of that time were adventurers
and revolutionaries,
consciously looking to travel to a new land,
west of California,
and bring back fresh kill for the human race.
That was a future.
They were actively out there making that new
future.
That's what's heroic, in the sense that people
felt like they could do heroic undertakings.
You could do whatever ... If you could dream
it, you could do it.
It was kind of like Walt Disney on ecstasy.
It's heroic when you do it in the face of
danger and opposition,
which you also had at the same time.
You were moving like Louis and Clark, into
this new territory, that was undefined.
That was unmapped.
That was full of danger in lots of ways.
Any company could go under at any moment.
Any weirdness could be popping out of the
things that you're discovering.
"Change is Good" is about six characters exploring
this new realm, like Louis and Clark,
going out into this uncharted territory and hoping
to discover what that was all about.
In fact, also helping to create our future.
It takes place in 1998, which is another pivotal
moment within a pivotal moment, because,
for most of the 90's, there was this expansionary
sense of the future looking incredibly wonderful.
Then there was this ton of money that flowed
into the sector in 1998.
What was the digital revolution, became the
.com bubble.
What was utopian became greed.
I'm trying to examine that particular tipping
point, between the moment when people had
fire in their eyes and wanted to change the
world, and they ended up being perverted,
in a kind of way, into, or seduced into, pursuing
the pure joy of making a lot of money.
I hope one day to experience that
myself.
If that was heroic age of the internet, how
would you characterize the internet now?
Or America now?
The internet does not seem to be particularly
heroic.
Does it?
I think the Internet's just become
part of our life.
It's gone from occult to the culture.
It's just everything that's normal today is
connected, as we said it would be,
to digital technologies and the networks themselves.
I think you have to look to other places to
see where this edge is today.
In many ways, what James is doing, is looking
for that edge again.
That Neolife?
That Neolife, exactly.
A lot of it is ... It's kind of interesting,
'cause baby boomers obviously also took charge
in the 90's.
I remember when Bill Clinton was the first
baby boomer president in '92.
Baby boomers have long been accused of being
solipsistic and inward-looking, but-
Totally true.
Also, now, literally, that's happening. Right?
'Cause we're looking at our own bodies and
changing them in ways that were unimaginable,
even a few years ago.
There's a new generation that's
pursuing this new adventure.
There are new adventurers out there.
I think, the Internet's become the background.
There's an edge.
There are still edges all over the place.
The genetic revolution is one of them.
Space is another.
Transportation is another one.
There are explorations to be had all over
the place.
The kind of incredible fervor that you saw
with the arrival of the internet,
that affected everything simultaneously all over the planet,
that kind of change is unlikely to happen in the same broad way that it did then.
Instead you have a bunch of little, or smaller,
changes that are erupting and that will become
their own major thing.
There are just lots of them happening out
there.
You also talk about the book, and
this brings us to Erik Spiekermann,
but it's a revolution in printing.
What is unique about the printing process?
Why the attention to that detail?
Why make a bunch of atoms, put together
a bunch of atoms, to experience the story,
instead of just putting it out digitally?
It's a very good question.
Because-
In the end, we also wanted to create another
experience.
There's a story, which is an abstraction in
lots of ways,
and then, there's a physical object of the book.
In lots of ways, books have become devalued
as they've migrated into the digital domain.
The book itself, as an object, has become
degraded.
It's a mass object that is not special, that
doesn't deliver a great experience.
The inks are not great.
The paper's not great.
The binding's not great.
Nothing about it is special.
We said, why don't we make a real ... Nevertheless,
it's still the best way to read things.
We like to read things on screen, but still
paper offers the best way to read.
We said, why don't we make a special experience.
The best experience we can make in the twenty-first
century, for reading itself.
That required Erik to begin an exploration
of printing itself.
He rediscovered an old way of printing, letterpress.
Instead of, the more normal way everything
is printed today, which is offset.
Letterpress is actually an image pressed into
a piece of paper.
It's something that got lost in mass-marketing,
because it just couldn't make the transition
to the new technologies for producing print.
What Erik has done, is reinvented a way of
producing plates for letterpress,
which enable you to use all the digital tools for publication,
but apply them to this classic technology of letterpress.
He created tools to make the plates that go
on the press.
This particular book, "Change is Good," is
among the very first to use his technology.
It's the first one that he's designing and
publishing himself.
It's just a special experience to read a crisp
type, impressed in the paper.
You actually have a physical impression in
the paper, which adds a third dimension
to the experience of reading.
We don't really know about anymore, because
everything we get is offset,
which is completely flat.
You have the experience of the impression
of the type on the paper,
and then you also have black ink, which you never get with offset.
Offset is, by definition, a variance of gray.
This ink that's pressed into the paper is
actually black.
Altogether the experience of reading, "Change
is Good," is basically state of the art
for the twenty-first century.
You also have thrown in a Spotify
soundtrack.
Also, because we can.
Yes.
If you look at the very beginning
of the book, there's a link to Spotify,
which enables you to listen to the soundtrack that
we put together, which is like 10 hours of music,
for listening to the book at your leisure.
We've known each other for about
20 years now, or coming up on 20 years.
One of the things over the past couple years
that ex- You have always been a maverick,
at a time when during Wired you seen as suspiciously
libertarian in your proclivities, and whatnot.
You have surprise a lot of people over the
past couple years by being, if not pro-Trump,
pro-Donald Trump, you are enjoying his intervention
into politics, into the political status quo.
How do you feel about him after a year in
office?
What is it about him that peaked your curiosity?
What is he bringing to the stage that you
think is really vital?
I think for most of my life, my
tendency has been to try to diminish the power
of the State, in general.
Part of that is literal power, and part of
it is the power that's in your head.
The presidency has taken on this otherworldly
position in people's minds
that is beyond Pope-hood.
It's this figure of immense authority that
you obliged to respect and that has all this-
and has the-
Because of the power of the United States
in general, has the ability
to project that power all over the planet.
I think Trump, in lots of ways, is a refreshing
reminder that the guy that's in the White House
is another human being.
The power of the State is way too exalted.
Bringing that power back to human scale is
an important part of what needs to be done
to correct the insanity that's been going
on in the post-war era,
where you have these large institutions that control all aspects of our lives.
Leaching respect and authority out of the
State, is kind of a good thing, on its own level.
Maybe I'll just leave it at that.
Well we will leave it there.
We've been talking with Louis Rossetto, the
co-founder of Wired and the novelist behind,
"Change is Good: A Story of the Heroic Era
of the Internet" and a revolution in printing.
Louis, thanks for talking.
Pleasure, as always.
For Reason, I'm Nick Gillespie.